I know what's the first step in writing
a screenplay it's getting the idea it's
sitting down and it's pulling out from
you and it's beginning to you know pull
the material together many times people
do outline sometimes they do treatment
sometimes they just get a couple
paragraphs of a story and then look at
it and say do I actually have a
beginning middle and end and do I have a
story so many people think that they
have the next big idea which is great in
they're enthusiastic about it when
should they then let others know so they
can bounce that not not too quickly
because you you need to sort of feel
your way through it it's not like it
comes to you full-blown generally so you
shouldn't hurry the process now
sometimes you might say I have five
ideas and you write them all in one
paragraph and then you say well which
one is the best maybe at that point you
might ask somebody let's say what do you
see going on here I'm not sure what
direction but if you really have
something pushing at you you know
something that's really heating up
there's an advantage to working it out a
bit and not letting people get in too
early because you don't want criticism
too early you want the flow is and you
want the excitement and the passion then
finding your way and even through a
draft or two you're probably still
finding your way to the story but then
there is a point you do need that
verification or evaluation from somebody
outside yourself and who would that be
because a mother a father sister
brothers probably will say it yes yes
well one of the first things to do is to
have friends who are writers and make
sure that they are constructive so you
don't want to give this to somebody who
reads your script and says oh no you
want to read it too soon and say okay I
can see exactly where its swords I
sometimes recommend that readers look
for where are they excited where are
they reading it and they feeling the
flow because it may not flow all the way
through
yet as still as to be rewritten at some
point many people do go to script
consultant and a script consultant is
meant to be the objective professional I
and again you want to find a positive
constructive script consultant not
someone who's there to tear it apart
you're there there that's supposed to be
there to build it up instead if you were
to arm a screenwriter with one tool or
weapon in terms of screenwriting
what would it be it's a imagination is
to have a flexible mind to be willing to
consider alternatives to recognize that
part of the screenwriters job is to
troubleshoot and to problem-solve
and that creativity and imagination and
the ability to say well you know I don't
have to set it in Chicago what if I said
it in Orlando Florida instead what if
what if it's a wonderful tool to ask
yourself what if instead of being by the
seaside it was and we're in the
mountainous what if instead of a Porsche
it were an old rattletrap forward that
reversal that flexibility of thinking is
what's really important because
someone's going to get to the rewriter
you're going to have a script consultant
or a director or a producer and actors
say this doesn't work what about and you
want your mind to be able to move with
that and for you to have an open mind
but on the other hand not to just let
anyone walk ramp shot over your script
because there's a lot of people that
will read a script and want to practice
their own creativity on your work and
say you have to be careful but you also
have to be open how would we know
someone like that like how would we know
the signs that it's actually someone
working at their own when when your gut
goes
you know something usually gets roiled
up that just doesn't feel right to you
or to your intention for the script so
sometimes somebody comes along and they
say well what if instead of a thriller
where horns no you know what I don't
like and so you have to know that
and it does take some time to recognize
and it also takes some time to recognize
that sometimes when people are throwing
out these ideas they are recognizing a
problem that they don't know how to
identify the problem so one of the
things is that problem analysis even
more than solution is important because
most people when they when they realize
what the problem is many times they can
solve it it's just they're kind of lost
and you do lose your objectivity and
it's hard I mean it is hard to find your
way many times can you talk about
writing a script week one versus at the
last week what that's like
stress is involved the highs the lows
well many writers they get very stressed
all the way through but there is a sense
where you recognize that the process is
the process it's it's not meant to be
smooth but you learn to say I'm in
process it's okay I know this scene
doesn't work it's okay for it not to
work today I'm going to think about this
I'm going to go back and you know rework
and of course toward the end many times
you're doing small things like doing
word changes saying this word has more
resonance than that word it's a better
choice
so you're rewriting all the way through
and there is a point when you feel good
and then you get it evaluated or you get
somebody else to read it I say oh my
that is just wonderful or here's eight
notes but don't do more and I've worked
on many scripts where I've said don't do
any more than this because this is
working and don't futz with that don't
don't
play around and say let say there's a
point you have to realize let it go now
maybe in the processes actors come in
there's going to be changes or a
director but there is a point you say
you know I think I've done the best I
can and I think it works
the screenwriter said hey can I take you
to coffee and have you given me some
tips on selling my screenplay would you
say well a flood of selling is who do
you know and I would encourage people
first of all I would encourage people to
submit their screenplays to to
screenwriting competitions when you
start getting a first place or a second
or third particularly in the big ones
the agents will come after you maybe a
producer will come after you so that's
one thing to do another thing is to make
relationships it is amazing how many
people that you meet one year pay off
five years later I I just ran into
somebody here that I knew as an
executive like 20 25 years ago and she
says remember when we used to have lunch
together I said oh yeah and I got a
phone call some time ago from a vice
president at CIA the agency
she says Linda remember we knew each
other when we were both starting out if
you have any people you want to send my
way I'm open to that and so these things
many times take a long time but the
other thing to remember is that people
are not just there to be your
opportunity people lie there because you
really like them and then you find over
a period of time that things start to
you know develop and you want to work
together because you enjoy and you truly
like each other and I think another
thing that's really important is to be
generous there is a tendency to see this
business as a competition rather than a
collaboration and I think changing the
way you see that becomes a real
breakthrough in this for writers as for
anybody in this business we as a speaker
these people are fab you
as colleagues of mine and when I started
out as a speaker and writing books and
what I felt competitive until one of my
company what a my colleague said to me
you know there's these seminar Wars
going on and who's the big guru and
who's the god of screenwriting and he
says I think it's ridiculous like that I
think you're right I've got it we've got
to all change our attitudes and it's a
joy to be at story Expo because I'm
seeing my colleagues and I'm meeting
some new people and I say yeah I'm
really glad I got over that and I think
that's what writers need to do relate to
each other and be generous with each
other so Linda let's say you're at a
place where you're not about competition
as much you've let some of that go but
you're sensing from someone else that
they more about that what's an approach
is to affirm them because many times
people feel competitive because of the
negatives and when you put the positive
in and to say for instance you are so
good at style or you are so funny or you
are I mean all mo that says I'm not
going to get hooked up by your
insecurities and I want to give above
that we have a saying in my office that
we treat everyone as human beings even
if they don't act to act like one once
in a while people don't act like human
beings say nevertheless you treat them
as a human being with respect and you
build them up and you nurture them and
you you help make them feel good about
themselves because that competition
comes from insecurity and and I mean we
all go there we all go those places the
big thing is is to fight it and to just
say I don't want to live here I don't
and I've been very interested in this
subject I wrote a book on this subject
called the better way to win connecting
not competing for success because I saw
so much and I worked so hard to overcome
this inside myself and I began to study
this whole idea of come
they took thinking so that I'm gonna
write a book on it so it's one of mine
on screen writing books a lesson about
yourself that you're almost embarrassed
to admit that you so long to realize
well I think we just talked about that
it was getting over my competitive
feelings and they were really knowing at
me and I worked really really hard at
that in the 1980s when I saw was when
those feelings are coming up and I just
resisted them I prayed about them I'm a
spiritual person and I just found you
know I I just said I don't want to live
here and and I would say that was
probably my biggest lesson in the
business say I don't want to go there
and they do pop up once in a while and I
just say don't want to go there no we're
not gonna go there
okay you're not gonna do this I think -
were in an age of social media where now
people can be competitive behind their
screen and say oh what's so and so
working on and there's a there's a
temptation to indulge ourselves how do
we stop that and say you know what I'm
just gonna focus on my life yeah
whatever they're doing is great for them
yes yeah and I mean I think that's just
what you do is you sit down and you
breathe deeply that's a lot of breathing
deeply that's very important and just
say what am I about and there is a thing
it's so easy to fall into that too to
get off-track and one of the things I
often say to myself and am I telling the
truth am I staying true to my calling
and said if I stay true you know whether
we call it our where we're being led or
called or however we want to say that
our mission and life our objective our
goal whatever if we stand that track I
think that's where we stay safe and it
so it becomes very important not to let
somebody else push us off that and and
sometimes that means it takes the data
answer an email that's trying to do it
or
to just sit down and then I got my
favorite rocking chair it's sitting row
and I just sit down say okay take a deep
breath I'm not gonna go there that is
not that is not where the good or that's
not where the value lies and it's not
where I want to live but it is work you
know it is is work to keep thing yes
we're not going to be there what's the
most common mistake a new screenwriter
makes well one thing is is to think that
there's just one draft and that is going
to flow out of them and that there's
nothing to learn as opposed to that
sense of a process but there is a very
fine balance between one's art and one's
craft the place that the flow happens
the place where you feel your voice is
being coming out and the shaping of the
voice the shaping of what that artistic
form is and it one has to be careful
about that balance because you learn a
lot about craft but it is this is an art
form it's not a paint-by-numbers it's
not saying oh my first turning point is
on page 27 instead of 32 oh my is say
well let's look more carefully because
maybe you're exactly in the right place
for that
and so there can be when people take
seminars and read books they can get
into the paint by numbers or on the
other hand you can have people who are
you know so into their art that they
don't want to learn and I say you can't
use it if you don't know it so knowledge
doesn't hurt you it just has to be put
in its right place and then there's the
danger of thinking that that first
screenplay is going to be the million
dollar idea with yes this weekend this
is that this is a work through and I
know that when I write my non-fiction
books I presume every chapter will be
rewritten at least five a minimum
but generally about ten times that'll be
gone over and over I ask an Emmy
award-winning screenwriter once I said
how many times you rewrite and she said
well this morning I rewrote the scene 22
times and my guess is she probably was
whether 22 is because she was a comedy
writer but my guess is it wasn't four
times and going over and over and saying
this word resonates better or not having
this line of dialogue but having an
image instead or having a reaction oh
yeah that is better and so you you
massage I mean you you really are
reworking and reworking and reworking
and sometimes people think well the
great writers I guess it just flows you
say no the great writers are probably
rewriting more than the merely good
writers and get used to the rewrite
process and get used to feedback and get
used to honing and tweaking and
recognize that's the process you
mentioned earlier about a writer finding
their own true voice within their work
how did you find yours well I came out
of theater and when I was first in
theater I presumed everyone in theater
would become an actor but I wasn't a
very good actor and I even took private
lessons and my acting teacher said this
is not natural to you she says now if
you want to work through whatever block
you have you know you can't we can work
on that but she said you know other
people as this flow is out of them much
more and I began to recognize that it
was in the field of first directing and
then literature and then I developed
this method and graduate school it
became the method that I use for my
consulting and when I started consulting
I realized it brought together all these
different parts of me I had a good
psychology background so I understood
the writer I had studied creativity
several years I knew about my own
creativity and it helped me understand
their creativity and I realized I was a
nurturer I was very good at nerd
during that creativity out of other
people and then when I started my
business I I sort of just went for it
and I went to a very good career
consultant who helped me affirm that
voice and along the way I had a mentor a
excellent teacher in graduate school
that kind of rather than saying you go
down this path he would watch the path I
was going down and he would encourage me
and he would he taught me how to be bold
don't be afraid to go out on a limb
don't be afraid heard something you
check it you know a certain extent but
says don't be afraid and so I began to
be much better about stepping out and
finding my own way and the more I could
get out of that coat competition and
just say look I'm only called to be me
I'm not asked to be anything else and
and I would go astray and thankfully I
had some good friends that would say do
you really want the red Porsche above
anything else in the world holders
there's something stronger and I I think
sometimes you keep saying what is
exactly my goal and you work at defining
that I mean if somebody said what is my
life about I would say my life is about
nurturing creativity and spirituality
and I see that these things come
together and so I mean I have this odd
degree a doctorate in drama and theology
which is the least marketable degree you
could get in the world but in terms of
the integration I think so many writers
want to do something important I say why
do we write we write because we want to
change the world we want to inspire we
want to examine and explore and express
the human condition and you know so we
we let that kind of flow out of us so
you keep your mind on the bigger goal
and you think what am I about and I just
have to stay true to that and you know
and sometimes is to learn to phrase what
it is that I am a
out what's my what's my mission or
what's important here and that helps
competition with an article sometimes
even this competition
it could be solely within us what could
be solely when someone else but it
sounds like once you define that you
just live by that kind of code yes and
we help each other a lot
my colleagues and I especially several
of them we call and sometimes when we
feel that sense whether it's competition
or anger or we're peeved about something
we call the other person and say okay I
gotta work through this and so I have
several colleagues and sometimes I call
you know like Pamela J Smith and I said
I have to be caddy for about 30 seconds
and Pamela says oh yeah no I had my dear
and so there are times that you do I
mean you do have those feelings and I
never want to negate that one has those
feelings but what I do is I have several
colleagues that are on call and when I
call them and say I just have to be kind
of my ugly self for a moment here is
that okay like oh yes honey go right
ahead okay got it out of my system okay
because I will have those feelings at
times and whatever those feelings are
uncertainty and security you know anger
we can go on and on about what those are
and say so yes having somebody to talk
to having good colleagues really valuing
those relationships and being there to
be generous to each other and to help
each other to recommend jobs for each
other to see what we can do for each
other knowing we all have our part to
play in this whole industry